good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that great thing that you have
inside you explode out into the world
and have a big impact so to help you on
your journey today's message is focus
over to you Will Smith I realized that
when you to have the level of success
that I want to have it's difficult to
spread it out and do multiple things you
know it's in order to to be world-class
and I've made a decision I want to be
world-class and it just it takes such a
desperate obsessive focus to to excel on
a certain honor on the level that I want
to make movies you know I was a Star
Wars when I was young i sat in the movie
theater and watched Star Wars and I just
couldn't believe that that movie made me
feel like that just floored and just
stunned by the creativity and just I'm
realizing that in order to move people
in that way in order to touch people in
that way you really got to focus with
all of your fiber and all of your heart
and all your creativity if you want to
be the best you need to focus on
anything if you want to be world-class
you want to be the best at anything you
need to focus a significant amount of
your time to get really really really
really good at it to be better than
everybody else because you put in the
time so as an example you look at look
at salsa dancing right trying to dance
salsa here by the time you finish level
1 after 9 hours of dance class with us
you can go out and dance at a club dance
to the music and impress your friends
but you're not world-class right
to get world-class you got to put in
tons and tons and tons of effort and so
there's a lot of these things that you
can learn quickly 8020 rule right you
can learn something really quickly and
your your growth goes like this but at
some point it starts to slow down at
some point as you get higher up there's
fewer people who can teach you if you
wanted to learn anything you wanted to
learn salsa dancing lots of people could
teach you the basics lots of people can
teach you some of the moves
but as you tap them out as you continue
to grow and learn there's fewer and
fewer people who are ahead of you
who can teach you and that's gonna be
applicable in any single industry if I
look at YouTube when I first started
doing these videos
I was consuming tons of information I
was watching all these videos that had
it be a youtuber and how to do camera
and how to be great on camera and all
all the different tips and tricks and
anybody could help me because everybody
was ahead of me there were tons of
people that I could learn from now as I
get better
there's very few people who I really
really really respect their opinions on
what they're doing because now I'm
beyond the 80% right I'm playing in that
20% the 20% is the mastery right and
it's even less than 8020 right it's more
like 95 five right I'm playing in the
five percent wherever already followed
all the best practices I'm already doing
everything that everybody says to do all
the experts say to do now I need to cut
my own path
right now we need to have my own
experiments now we need to push the
boundaries even more when you get to
that level when you get to be that good
whatever it is that you do that's when
you become a master and it's by that
obsessive focus to say I want to get
really really really really good at this
and so there's tons of skills and you
could pick up and you could be
proficient at and you can learn really
quickly you can learn the 80% of it
really really quickly and impress your
friends and have some skills but if you
want to get really really really really
good at something you're gonna have to
focus and what happens a danger is as
you grow in as you get better you're
gonna get tons of people giving you
opportunities that will distract your
focus or just entrepreneurs in general
we liked it oh I could do this and I
could do this and I could pick that
shiny fruit over there that can go in
this direction we like distractions
right we love dreaming and thinking and
that prevents you from focusing on the
thing that you're doing so many
entrepreneurs are just they're little
they're little Pyro's they love starting
little fires everywhere and as a result
like nothing ever becomes this huge
bonfire right build the big bonfire stop
lighting tiny fires everywhere else
that's where you have massive success
focused effort on one thing so I've got
big TV producer saying we want to make a
TV show with you we want to make a movie
with you I've got a billionaire who
wants to buy my channel
it's like I'm not even looking at that
stuff I don't thank you it's it's a
great problem to have I'm not
complaining but I can't focus on that
stuff because as soon as I started
looking over here I start doing that
then I'm not focused on this thing
anymore and what I want to do is make
great content for you right and I don't
want to be distracted by other
opportunities and as you continue to
grow and as you continue doing your
thing you will get distracted you will
get distracted by other people you get
distracted by yourself you get
distracted by your ideas and if you
really want to do something great you
really want to be world-class at
something you really want to build that
huge bonfire then you have to focus
so the question day today is I'm curious
what is the thing that you want to focus
on and be world-class at one of the best
in the world at this particular crafter
skill what is that leave it down the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Charlie Funk Charlie thank
you so much for picking up the e copy of
my book through one word I really
appreciate the support and I hope you
enjoyed the reading so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
we ink in this venture capital from her
a lot to take on are there are there
other things it seems like kind of each
of your vehicles maybe has a specific
purpose are there other areas and things
that you're looking at and want to
pursue with spacing right because you
know we have there are certain things
that we want to get to but we have to
pace those out because we have to have
absolute focus on a few of those things
right Brian stipple fun and the stories
that we are creating right those are two
lenses right now there are other things
that are going to come but that's way
down the road you know we have to have a
very very sharp winds because we can do
so many things me that's the hardest
part when we first started it is you
have so many people coming from
different different angles different
points of view and you can do this you
can do that and you know it's a lot of
them are very lucrative offers but their
small window my opportunities and the
hardest parts been pushing those to the
side and going through things that have
a much much longer tail which is risky
but you know what are you gonna do nice
I think that's the best way to go about
it before I did Seinfeld I was very
bleak I would wake up in the morning and
my first thought in my head was oh no
you know oh I got to go through this now
what day another day yeah but one
Seinfeld started all those thoughts were
gosh I feel did what for you it gave you
it gave me a reason to I don't know it
it focused me on something but success
and give you confidence I guess yeah I
don't know you know when you're working
hard your focus you just you just do it
you don't really think about it your
environment is so important and if you
look at be performers or see producers
they really don't pay a lot of tension
to their environment and so they get
very distracted there's lots of noises
their phones are going off maybe there's
news in the background maybe there's mad
see environments all around them maybe
there's toxic people what I'm suggesting
to you is the second piece of technology
to really 100 times your productivity is
this install environments of tight
bubbles of total focus the way I run my
work life on certain days
I am very hard to reach and I challenge
you with great love and respect be very
hard to reach during key times of your
week I mean I see a lot of people and
it's not judging them it's just
observing them every time their phone
rings they check it or they have you
know these loud notifications so they're
constantly being distracted and we know
what the research says the research says
we spend 2.1 hours a day in distraction
we spent and it takes 21 minutes to
refocus your focus after you've been
distracted so if you are being
distracted by notifications checking
your phone checking your Twitter feed
checking your Facebook feed looking on
Instagram checking all the different
platforms that is going to destroy your
focus so the second piece of technology
is create these tight bubbles of total
focus and the way I do it is I have
certain days that I label as creative
days and on those creative days I
actually go device free and on those
days I'm very hard to find and on those
days I'm in total solitude and on those
days I go to certain places I called
them my Menlo labs just like Edison had
his Menlo lab and these places are very
minimalist and there's no one there and
that's where I do my best work so
install these tight bubbles of total
focus and create these Menlo labs where
you're sorry you're completely
distraction free and then you will find
your brain will drop from the beta state
into the alpha state where you will do
your best work and get your best ideas
lowers volume you have the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details